yeah so this is going to be a video
about one image that appears in one
tweet that simply tells us that Elden
Rings DLC is coming and I'm gonna try
and make this a good video because yes I
am going to present some truly unhinged
speculation about the contents of the
DLC but most importantly this is
actually the perfect excuse to discuss a
few things that we haven't dived into
yet on this channel for example we've
yet to discuss torrent whose mysterious
Origins are clearly being teased here
and I also want to talk about the dark
side of the earth tree which is
absolutely a huge part of the law
already so my goal in this video even if
my predictions are wrong is to at least
gear you up with some knowledge about
the game's law that you can take with
you no matter where the DLC actually
takes us and my other goal with this
video is to let you know that my art
book is currently 10 off for a limited
time
first and foremost let's talk about who
is riding torrent in this image because
out of everything I talk about in this
video this is the thing that I'm most
certain of now at first when I saw this
my mind went immediately to it being
Queen America because of that braided
Golden Hair they're also riding torrent
sitting in a side saddle manner which
was historically a way for a woman to
sit on Horseback with dignity while
wearing a dress the character is also
wearing a similarly placed upper armband
so while it's definitely possible that
this could be a Young America I still
think that that's nowhere near as likely
as the alternative I'm about to suggest
which is that this person is mikola who
was one of America's many demigod
children so item descriptions and
dialogue all refer to Nicola as a he
however Nikola does have the feminine
side to match the person riding torrent
in this image like literally they have a
feminine old torigo called Saint Trina
if any of this is news to you then I
recommend you go and watch my recent 47
minute long lore video on mikola that
explains so much about their character
but in that video I talked about all the
known statues of mikola which feature
them in a long Garb that actually cuts
off at the elbow and looking back this
is the exact same Garb that this
character is wearing what's more the
hair here while it is braided like
Americas it's also long and flowing and
just the style is identical to Nicholas
as you can clearly see in the opening
cinematic America's hair by contrast is
always symbolically depicted as two
Standalone braids and not to mention
depictions of America are always of her
in full Womanhood but this figure is
Meek and they're childlike by comparison
so in my eyes this is definitely mikola
who was cursed to Eternal childhood also
in regards to the tweet it does say rise
tarnished and let us walk A New Path
together which kind of reminds me of
what I said in the recent Mickler video
where I speculated a lot about how
mikola's intent might be to plant a new
world order and perhaps to walk A New
Path
so if we are correctly assuming that
this is mikola then we can also finally
start to unravel the mystery surrounding
torrent your spectral Steed and that's
important because torrent is not just
some random Mount he's a full-on
character and for whatever reason he
chose you as his tarnished down to the
very moment where he sniffs you out in
the stranded graveyard melaner is
actually an unwitting part of this plan
to find and guide you she has no real
memory or knowledge of whatever plot
that she's a part of Beyond following
torrent's own guidance which she then
passes on to you by giving you a golden
ring which doubles as a whistle someone
who does seem to know a bit more about
torrent is Ronnie who you might remember
at the very start of the game entrusts
you with three Lone Wolf spirits and
they give you a spirit calling Bell as
well and Ronnie says that these are from
Torrance former Master I'd heard tale of
a tarnished hurkin about Atop A spectral
Steed I was entrusted this for thee my
tolerance former master
now you could argue that she's referring
to Melina as Torrance former Master here
but then that doesn't really make sense
because why would Rani bother to hide
Melina's identity as Torrance former
Master if we've met Melanie already so I
think that Torrance former Master is
surely some other third party someone
who is clearly very in tune with Spirits
considering torrent is himself a spirit
and considering the spirit calling Bell
and the three lone wolves are all from
the same person speaking of the three
wolf Spirits there's actually a relief
in pharah Missoula that depicts three
wolves crowded around a small slight
figure whoever owned torrent would have
also owned the three wolf Spirits so
I've always wondered if this image was
depicting Torrance former master and
whoever Torrance former master was they
were someone that was able to compel
both Melina and Rani to seek you out on
their behalf my best guess until now was
that it was Mara doing this as we know
she goes to Great Lengths to help the
tarnished even hug forges weapons for
you on America's behalf and he even
speaks of a spirit caller that he once
knew so yeah I always thought the spirit
caller might have been Marika until now
because considering this image I think
we really have to entertain the
possibility that Torrance former Master
could have been mikola as you may know
mikola had a famous ability to compel
the affection and loyalty of others so
it's also very easy to think then that
Rani Melina torrent and even huge might
have intervened to assist you on
mikola's behalf Nikola was also a
talented Craftsman who might have
crafted the golden spectral Steed
whistle ring anyway for now this is just
all speculation but at the very least I
think we are getting closer to learning
about Torrance former Master here for
sure and finally what's with the dark
urge in the distance this is the last
thing I want to discuss because this is
the thing I think you can be the least
sure of and I'm kind of just going to
throw a lot of theories at the wall and
see if anything sticks but it's a really
fascinating concept so whatever this
tree is whatever's happened to this
earth tree it's weeping gold and it does
still seem to be a source of light just
like the Earth tree is in game except
now it has a weak Golden Light That
filters from behind its branches at
first I thought it might be Nicholas
Hayley tree which does seem to curve in
a similar Manner and as we discussed in
this video Nicholas halik tree is a sort
of herd tree although it is an entry
that has already split and withered so
I'm not that drawn to this Theory and
actually if you look closely it's almost
as if there's two trees here one that is
straighter like the old tree that has a
streak of gold within it and a light
filtering behind its Brown inches and
then there's another tree that is almost
twisting around it almost as if it's
strangling the old tree and literally
could be sapping the Vitality from it
the only entity that I'd think would be
capable of this in the current game at
least would be Godwin's Black Death
route this would certainly explain the
color of the trees the Strangling
Behavior and the sort of black falling
Decay that they have and if mikla is
part of this DLC then you'd think that
Godwin would be a part of things as well
considering how entwined their histories
are but of course this is all just one
line of speculation you can go down so
many you can also try to think about
when this event might occur and I feel
like you can make valid Arguments for
and against it being in almost every
time period if it's in the past that
explains mikola's healthy State and
torrent being unsettled by you but then
it doesn't explain the state of the urge
tree and if it's in the future then it
might suggest that this takes place
after you become Eldon Lord but then
what if I chose the frenzy ending how
does Mycologist take Torrent from you
shouldn't Nicola's future be with Moog
and then there's the theory that this
could be some sort of alternate reality
altogether whether that's in the past
present or future and I quite like this
idea considering mikola has a whole
storyline where they also exist within
some sort of Dreamscape as their Alias
which is Saint Trina and also the
landscape here doesn't really look like
the lands between that we know the
mountains seem too low the wheat field
seems too vast so what if this is some
sort of spirit Realm
speaking of spirit Realms the old tree
being black and the spirit Graves and
torrent who is also a spirit these
things make me want to talk about the
black lamp wood of the helfin to a lot
of you those random words I just said
probably made no sense they're actually
words that only really show up in one
item description but if you weren't
aware the hellfun is described as being
a sort of dark counterpart to the Earth
tree in the sense that it also offers a
type of guidance except its guidance is
offered to the heroic dead of the spirit
world we talk more about the helfin and
the lamp wood and this guidance in this
video on death so if you're interested
in speculating down that particular
Rabbit Hole I'd recommend that video
to be honest the shadow of the old tree
is such an extremely evocative title
that there really are so many things
that I think it could be referring to
for example a big part of me wonders if
we're supposed to reject the first
impression that this image gives us
remember when Eldon Rings first
cinematic trailer dropped and everyone
thought that Radigan was shattering the
olden ring that's clearly what the
trailer wanted you to think considering
the narration but really Radigan was
actually repairing the olden ring and
the true story was way more complex so I
feel like we shouldn't rule out the
possibility that this image might not
depict the old tree dying what if this
image is instead depicting a scene from
long ago back when the earth tree was
first coming into existence this is an
idea I put forward in my earliest lore
video for Elden ring and in that video I
stated that an existing great tree might
have been taken over by the parasitic
golden urge tree and I admit I was way
too sure of myself when I presented that
theory I basically presented it as fact
which was wrong however I still think
that that theory has some validity
because we do know that a crucible of
chaotic life existed within the
primordial oak tree and we know that the
crucible was related to Great tree
ornamentation as shown by The Crucible
Knights and there are suggestions that
the great tree roots are a distinct
thing from old tree roots so I do think
that it's worth considering that a great
tree existed before the old tree and
that the Earth tree might have taken it
over in a sense so I do want to
cautiously put forward that theory again
for consideration however moving on last
theory on the Urge tree I do want to
mention that shadow and darkness are
kind of already related to the odd tree
via the two fingers despite how ironic
that might sound right you wouldn't
think the darkness and Shadow are
related to this tree that is all about
warmth and light and abundance but
Darkness does play A Part Servants of
the two fingers were known to cast
spells such as darkness and Assassin's
approach which helped them in
assassinating the tarnished that had
strayed from the guidance of Grace not
to mention the two fingers being these
envoys of the greater will were capable
of bestowing Beastly living Shadows to
prominent characters most notably Rani
who was given blithe and America who was
given malikath so the title could be
referring to these Shadows but again I
really am throwing all kinds of ideas
out now so they really could be doing
anything when it comes to the setting
and the time period of it all so what do
you think but moving on from the old
tree and torrent and their Rider what
else do we see in this image well again
there are these ghostly Graves with
holes in their Center and funnily enough
in a recent Secrets video we talked
about how from software loves reusing
these cut God's grave assets from Dark
Souls 3 and the asset actually has
reappeared in Elden ring already there's
one Grave Just Like These at morne
Castle where you fight the leonine Miss
begotten it's also not the first
instance of physical objects having a
ghostly presence in the world you can
also see this in Langdale with the
ghostly flagpoles and I'll be honest I
don't really know what this means Beyond
it being a sort of spiritual overlap of
Worlds perhaps or maybe these are time
periods that persist spiritually somehow
I don't know
and then you can also see a couple of
stone coffins in the image as well these
Stone coffins appear all over the lens
between and it's here that you might
have picked up a ton of runes if you
could have defeated the wolves that
often guard these sort of cemeteries
anyway I'm getting the vibe that there's
going to be quite a long wait until
Elden ring DLC is ready I'm kind of
expecting the worst but hoping for the
best but I don't really expect a trailer
anytime soon I think the next most
likely time would be around Summer Games
Fest in early June but then they did
drop this random announcement on a
random Tuesday so who knows what from
software is thinking honestly anyway
before I fall asleep I want to quickly
talk to you guys about version 2 of my
art book which is soul Arts which is
currently 10 Off fuel until the end of
March as long as you enter the code
soulards 10 at checkout if you're
unfamiliar Soul Arts is designed to be
the ultimate art book for any fan of
from software's games it enshrines the
hard work of over 100 artists and tells
unique stories that are inspired by
these games the book is split into five
chapters and each asks a question what
if bloodborne 2 was real what if you
could explore other lands in Dark Souls
what other prosthetic tools could secure
have used what is beyond the broken
sixth Archstone of demon souls and what
did we think Elden ring would be back
when we knew nothing if you bought
during the kickstarter you would have
received version one of Soul Arts which
is still gorgeous with glossy pages and
deep blacks and colors that look amazing
in optimal lighting conditions but
version 2 uses a thicker more matte
paper that brings a few more details out
of the darkness and makes for a slightly
easier reading experience but it's the
same book in the end even if it is a
little bit thicker and again it's 10 off
for a very limited time so make use of
that by using the discount Link in the
description while you can but thank you
as always for watching and I'll see you
next time